قال المبعوث الامومي الى اليمن مارتن
جريفث انه يعمل للبناء على اتفاق تبادل
الاسرى بين الحكومه اليمنيه والحوثيين
لتمهيد الطريق امام وقف اطلاق نار شامل
يعقبه حل سياسي ويشمل اتفاق التبادل
الاسرى الذي اشرفت عليه الامم المتحده
اطلاق نحو الف اسير بينهم سعوديون
وسودانيين
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا كان هذا خبر حلقتنا
نناقش ما وراء هذا الخبر ما هي المؤشرات
التي يبعثها اتفاق الحكومه اليمنيه
والحوثيين على تبادل اطلاق الاسرى في هذا
التوقيت وما هي امكانيه البناء على
الاتفاق لانجاز ما سماه جريفث وقفا شاملا
لاطلاق النار يفضي الى حل سياسي في
[موسيقى]
اليمن
1081 من الاسرى والمحتجزين سيسترد حريتهم
وفق الاتفاق الذي اعلن المبعوث الاممي الى
اليمن مارتن جريفث ان الحكومه اليمنيه
والحوثيين توصلوا اليه في ختام مشاورات في
سويسرا اتفاق تبادل الاسرى يفتح الطريق
امام هدف ظل يبشر به منذ فتره تحت عنوان
الاعلان المشترك وهو وفق جريفث وقف اطلاق
نار يفضي في نهايه المطاف الى حل سياسي
لهذه الازمه هدف لم يستبعده رئيس لجنه
الاسرى والمعتقلين التابعه للحوثيين عبد
القادر مرتضى الذي اكد ايضا حضور الجانب
السعودي في مشاورات سويسرا وتوقع حضورا
اماراتيا في الجوله
المقبله لقد اتفقتم على الاطلاق الفوري
لصلاح
1081 شخصا والاجتماع مجددا لبحث مساله
الافراج عن المزيد كجزء من التزامكم
بالافراج عن جميع السجناء والمحتجزين
المرتبطين بالنزاع الذين يشملهم قرار مجلس
الامن الدولي من المهم الان الانتقال
بسرعه وبشكل حاسم الى مرحله التنفيذ لا
يوجد وقت لنضيعه واتفاق الافراج هذا يعد
العمليه الاكبر في تاريخ النزاع في
اليمن الملف الاسرى هو من ملفات بناء
الجاه وفي حال اي تقدم في هذا الملف سيؤسس
كما نعمل لان يكون هناك اتفاقات مشابهه في
الجانب السياسي وفي الجوانب الاخرى ان شاء
الله نعم هناك حضور سعودي في هذه الجوله
وايضا في الجوله السابقه في عمان
والسعوديون حاضرون بقوه في هذه المفاوضات
لان لديهم الكثير من الاسرى لدينا ولدينا
الكثير من الاسرى لديهم وفي سجونهم
وحضورهم كان هاما جدا لانه لا يوجد اي طرف
يفاوض على الاسرى السعوديين
وفي نحن موعودون ايضا بان تكون الجوله
القادمه ان تشمل ايضا حضور اماراتي
للتفاوض مع الامارات را لان لديهم الكثير
من الاسرى التابعين
لنا ومناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
صنعاء نصر الدين عامر وكيل وزاره الاعلام
التابعه للحوثيين ومن واشنطن عبر الانترنت
الدكتور نبيل خوري نائب رئيس البعثه
السياسيه الامريكيه في اليمن سابقا ابدا
بضيفي من صنعاء نصر الدين عامر هل هذا
الاتفاق يمثل اختراقا اي بالنظر الى انه
كانت هنالك اتفاقات كثيره لتبادل الاسرى
في م قبل بين القبائل و ومختلف المحافظات
ما الجديد في هذا الاتفاق كي يعتبر
اختراقا يبنى عليه للوصول الى وقف اطلاق
النار ثم اتفاق
سياسي نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اولا
هذا الاتفاق هو يعني ملف الاسرى هو من
ملفات بناء الثقه التي كان يفترض ان تنفذ
قبل مفاوضات السويد لتؤسس ثجا والولوج في
مفاوضات السويد لكنه تاخر الى اليوم وكان
من ضمن اتفاق السويد كان نقطه من النقاط
وتحول الى نقطه خلافيه لانه لم تكن هناك
جديه من الطرف الاخر للتبادل الان جاءت
هذه النقطه نحن نعتبرها انها خطوه ايجابيه
تمهد
لاستكمال النقاط التي هي متعلقه ببناء
الثقه التي طرحت في حينها في مفاوضه سويد
لبناء الثقه مثل يعني الان من الملفات
الملحه مثلا ملف ميناء الحديده واغلاق هذا
الميناء مطار صنعاء ملف المرتبات وصرف
مرتبات يعني موظفي الدوله هذه ملفات
انسانيه كلما نفذت منها يعني كلما نفذ
منها ملف كلما كنا اقرب الى الدخول الى
الملفات الاكثر حساسيه وهو الملف العسكري
والملف السياسي للوصول الى وقف كامل لهذ
الحرب لانه اذا لم يكن هناك جديه في ملفات
انسانيه ذات تبادل مصلحه للطرفين وهي تخص
اسر هؤلاء الاسرى فانه لن يكون هناك اي
تقدم في ملفات ذات حساسيه عاليه مثل ملفات
ونحن نشاهد ملف اتفاق الحديده الى الان لم
ينفذ يعني نف فذ من طرف صنعاء فقط كمبادئ
وومن الطرف الاخر لم يكن هناك اي تنفيذ
اذا نحن امام خطوه جيده نعتبرها خطوه
بدايه وهي جزء يعني كان الاتفاق ان ان
يعني ان يطلقوا الجميع مقابل الجميع وما
نفذ الان هو جزء من نقطه من بناء الثقه
يعني هنالك 15000 اسير
ومحتجزة
المبعوث الاممي مارتن جريفث هل هو تفاؤل
في محله بان هذا الاتفاق ربما يؤدي في
النهايه الى وقف اطلاق نار ثم اتفاق
سياسي مع الاسف مارتن جريفز سهل جدا
تفاؤله وكلما يبدا بتقرير امام مجلس الامن
يقول انا متفائل والكل يريد كذا وكذا انا
يعني مع اهميه ملف
الاسرى اخشى ان نقع في في ملف مثل ما وقع
جريفس في ملف الحديده من قبل واستغرق
حوالي سنتين والحرب مستمره ولم يحصل لا
على هذه ولا على تلك فاليوم يعني مساله
تبادل اسرى مساله انسانيه ولا تضطر الامم
المتحده لكي تتدخل فيها الفرقاء اطراف
بينهم يجب ان يتفاهموا بمساعده منظمات
مجتمع مدني يعني وخاصه في اليمن امهات
الاسرى والمخطوفين
ومؤسسات حقوق الانسان المختلفه المتمثله
في اليمن الصليب الاحمر يمكن كلها ان
تتفاوض في موضوع انساني من هذا النوع
وليحفظ مارتن جريف تدخله في الامور
السياسيه الكبرى ويحاول انهاء هذه الحرب
ولكن ما الذي يمنع ان يتدخل في هذه الامور
ايضا لانه يغرق فيها كما قلت يعني تدخل في
مساله الحديده وغرق فيها وترك الحرب على
اوجها في الشمال والجنوب والوسط اليمني
وغرق في تفاصيل الحديده فالان يغرق في
تفاصيل الاسرى يعني تبادل الاسرى تحدثوا
عنه في الكويت ثم في ستوكهولم وفي عمان في
عمان اتفقوا على اطلاق كل الاسرى واليوم
نع ونتحدث عن الف وعلى ما سمعت اليوم انه
يستثنى من هؤلاء الالف
الصحفيين لماذا يستثنى الصحفيين هذه علامه
سيئه لانه مع انهاء الحرب وانهاء العنف
يجب ان ننتبه الى مراعاه حقوق الانسان
وحريه الكلمه والحجز على الصحفيين منا انه
الاطراف مصره على احتجاز الكلمه تمام ينضم
الينا من تعز عبر الانترنت الدكتور فيصل
الحذيفي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
الحديده طبعا محمد الحضري وزير الخارجيه
اليمني اعتبر هذا الاتفاق يعني حصره في
الاطار الانساني فقط لكن هنالك تسريبات
تتحدث عن انه ال الاسماء التي طرحها
المندوب السعودي لم تكن للحكومه اليمنيه
على علم بها وكانها مسارات مختلفه وكان
الحوثي يتفاوض مع مسارات مختلفه وليس مع
مسار واحد ما الذي حققته الحكومه
في هذا
المسار اسعد الله مسائكم بالخير الحكومه
اليمنيه لم تعد طرفا فاعلا في المفاوضات
او في الحرب او في السلم لانها سلمت الملف
الى الطرف السعودي الذي يتصرف وفق مصالحه
سواء بمفاوضات المباشره مع
الحوثيين دون علم الحكومه اليمنيه
وبالتفاح مع الرباعيه التي ليست الحكومه
اليمنيه والدوله اليمنيه طرفا فيها وكذلك
هي التي تحدد الاسماء الان الاسماء
السعوديه المطروحه في تبادل الاسرى
والحقيقه هو هم ليسوا تبادل اسرى يعني في
في ثمت مغالطات في الموضوع اول مره من
تحديد العدد ثانيا بتحديد التسميه ا كل ما
لدى الحوثيين ليسوا
اسرى وهم على الاقل فيما يخص الطرف اليمني
الجانب الشرعي يعني معظمهم مختطفين او
مخفيين قصر
بينما من هم بيد الجيش الوطني هم اسراء
حرب فعلا في المعارك وبالتالي المستفيد
الاوفر في المستفيد الاوفر في هذا الجانب
الحوثيين من جهه انهم يفاوض على اسرا
يخصونه وكذلك السعوديه تفاوض على اسماى
سعوديه او جنود سعوديين تم اسرهم في في
الحدود هذه هي اذا الجانب اليمني والجانب
الانساني غائب في المساله هل دعنا نسال
ضيفنا من صنعاء عن تلك النق نقطه نصر
الدين عامر ا يعني حسب المعلومات التي
وردت الينا فانه الاسماء التي طرحتها
الحكومه اليمنيه الكثير منها من المدنيين
الاسماء التي طرحت للافراج عنها كثير منها
مدنيين محتجزين لدى الحوثيين هل لك ان
تعلق على هذه النقطه كيف يمكن ان ان يفرج
عن مقاتلين حوثيين ومقاتلين او جنود
سعوديين وجنود سودانيين ثم القائمه التي
يفرج عنها للحكومه اليمنيه هي من المدنيين
في معظمها هل هذا صحيح
اولا هذا غير صحيح ابدا انتم شاهدتم في
عمليه نصر من الله الاف الاسرى كانوا في
يعني في محافظه او في الحدود مع محافظه
صعده مع السعوديه في عمليه نصر من الله في
وادي ال ابو جباره وفي منطقه كتاف كذلك في
جبهه نهم كان هناك الاف الاسرى هل هؤلاء
مدنيين هذه مغالطه ثم ان الاسرى
السودانيين والسعوديين هل هم مختطفين هل
ذهبنا لاختطافه من الرياض ومن يعني من ام
درمان هذا غير صحيح وهذه مغالطه دائما يذب
على الحديث عنها وان اطلاق الاسرى هو
لمصلحه الطرف اليمني هذه شهاده لنا باننا
احرص منهم على انجاح هذا الملف وبان انا
حريصين على مقاتلينا ان نطلق من السجون
تحت يعني ولو قد تمنا اي تنازلات الطرف
الاخر يقم من هذه المغالطات وليس جاات في
تبادل الاسرى ويذهب الى الحديث بانه
مختطفون ثم ان معظم اسرانا اليوم والكثير
منهم يتم اختطافهم وهم مسافرون الى الخارج
في مارب كما حدث ل بعض العائدين من الحج
ومعروفين تم تبادلهم باسرى من الجبهات
مقابل ناس تم اختطافهم في مدينه مارب وهم
في طريقهم الىى السفر اما للعلاج او
للدراسه بالخارج ولكننا لا نذهب الى هذه
المغالطه هذه النقطه جانبا الان لكن هذا
هذه الخطوه اتفاق تبادل الاسرى هي خطوه
لبناء الثقه ما هي
الضمانات التي توجد في هذا الاتفاق لبناء
الثقه لضمان تنفيذ هذا الاتفاق هل هنالك
ضمانات محدده تم الاتفاق
عليها الى الان لا لا ليس هناك ضمانات
بحسب كلام رئيس لجنه
الاسرى يعني اللجنه الوطنيه للاسرى
الاستاذ عبد القادر المرتضى بانه يعني يتم
التفاوض والحديث عن ما هي الضمانات لكن
الى الان حسب علمي لا ليس هناك اي ضمانات
واضحه الضمانات ان الطرفين لديهم اسر هذا
المفترض ان تكون ضمانه ولكن هنا دعني ان
اؤكد بخصوص السعوديه كان في الماضي ايام
الملك عبد الله كان اكثر حرص على الجنود
السعوديين اما محمد بن سلمان فهو ليس لديه
اي حرص كنا في السابق نعتقد بان استهداف
الجيش السعودي او اسر جنود من الجيش
السعودي سيستفاد
ايام الملك عبد الله اما ايام محمد بن
سلمان فالجن السعودي ليس له قيمه واقتل من
السعوديين لن يتاثر ولن يرف له جفن يعني
هو ليس الذي حسس هؤلاء الاصر السعوديين
لهم فقد مع حضور مندوب سعودي والافراج
والاتفاق على الافراج عن 15 جنديا سعوديا
بل ار الجنود سودانيين كانوا بجانب
السعودين لا نريد ان نخذ كثيرا في هذه
النقطه لان خارج موضوع النقاش اسال نبيل
خوري من واشنطن ما الضمانات المطلوبه كي
تؤتي هذه الخطوه ثمارها وهي بناء
الثقه يعني انا غير متفائل كثيرا بهذه
الخطوه عاده تنهى الحروب ويتم تبادل الاسر
من بعد ذلك حتى لا يكون هنالك تخوف من اي
من الاطراف بان من يطلق راهم يعودوا
ويشاركوا في الحرب مره اخى مره اخى اي على
كل حال اذا كان تم اطلاق سراح الاسرى
لاسباب انسانيه قبل نهايه الحرب فلا يجب
ان يكون هنالك تفاوض وحسابات من هو الكاسب
ومن هو الخاسر اذا كان السبب انساني
فليطلقها اسير واحد فقط من جانب
و15000 من جانب اخر فليتم التبادل معليش
مش ربح وخساره اذا كان انساني يعني انساني
يشمل الجميع وهذا ما يجب ان يحصل الان
وهذا ما سيبني الثقه على شرط ان يتبادلوا
كل الاسرى مره واحده وليس بدفعات وليس
بتصنيفهم فئات
مختلفه هذا من
جانب من جانب ولذلك انت تركز على او تطالب
المبعوث الاممي بان يركز على الحل السياسي
لكن الحل السياسي صعب سيد نبيل خوري الحل
السياسي صعب يحتاج قوه
كثيره وبناء الثقه لا دايره من بناء الثقه
قبل ان ان تتفهم الاطراف على حلول سياسيه
ما المانع في
ذلك ليس ليس من مانع ولكن يعني ثلاث سنوات
ونحن نتحدث عن بناء الثقه وانا ثقتي شخصيا
بمارتن جريفث انعدمت غير موجوده اليوم
لانه لم يحقق شيء فنقول انه صنع السلام
صعب بالطبع صعب ولكن يعني هو وظيفته ايش
انه يخذ المسائل الهينه وحتى المسائل
الهينه تقدم هو تقدم بالحل المشترك البيان
المشترك وهو خاص بوقف اطلاق النار هل هل
هذه الخطوه واسال ضيفي من تعز السيد فيصل
الحذيفي هل هل يمكن البناء على ما تم
الاتفاق عليه في سويسرا اليوم للانطلاق
الى دفعه جديده من الاسرى كما قال مارتن
جريفث ثم بعد ذلك الموافقه على اطلاق وقف
كامل لاطلاق النار في اليمن هل هذا يبدو
امرا سهل التحقيق في المستقبل
القريب اولا الحديث عن الف اسير وبعضهم
مختطفين و مخفين قصرين ليس بذلك
الجانب المشبع ل ما يخص الجانب الانسان
اليمني نحن نتحدث عن عشرات الالافات من
المخفيين قصرين في سجون الحوثيين هم خارج
سياق المفاوضات هذا اولا ثانيا ثلاث
سنوات يعني تركنا
جوهر تفاهمات اتفاقيه ستوكهولم
وذهبنا الى الى الى مقدمه هذه التفاهمات
وهي بناء الثقه متى سننتقل من بناء الثقه
الى الى
تنفيذ يعني محاور التفاهمات التي هي
استعاده
او تنفيذ القوات المشتركه استعاده الثلاثه
موان الموارد الى البنك المركزي صرف
الرواتب فك الحصار عن تعز يعني في نهايه
الامر هي جهد لا يمكن ان يفضي الى ما يمكن
ان يشبع متاب الفضول المتابع اليمني
للماسي الانسانيه التي تجاوز 1000 اسير
اليوم نتحدث عن عن ماسي انسانيه مضحكه حول
1000 اسير بعينهم حددتهم السعوديه او
حددهم الحوثيون والحكوم والحكومه اليمنيه
هي خارج اطار هذا التص تصور يعني بالهامش
يعني اليس اليس حصار تعز جانب انساني اليس
ايقاف الرواتب اربع سنوات عن الموظفين
اليم من جانب انساني اليس الفقر والجوع
والحصار اليمني والقتل الممنهج جانب
انساني ابقاء الحديده ايضا يعني في نهايه
الامر في امور تح هك اش كجانب الانسان لكن
هو سؤالي دكتور فيصل هذه الخطوات التي
اتخذت ودعني احيلك ايضا الى تصريح نائب
وزير الدفاع السعودي الامير خالد بن سلمان
نعم يوم الثلاثاء الذي قال نسعى مع دعاه
السلام واشقائه في اليمن للوصول الى سلام
شامل ودائم من خلال تنفيذ اتفاق الرياض
وتكامل الجهود مع المبعوث الاممي لانجاح
مقترح المقترح الاعلان المشترك لانهاء
الازمه وعوده اليمن الى محيط الخليج
والعربي هو يتحدث عن وقف ايضا كامل لاطلاق
النار وهو المقترح هذا مقترح مارتن جريفث
الا يقرا من ذلك انه الاجواء باتت مهيئه
على الاقل من جانب التحالف السعودي
الاماراتي
ل الوصول الى ما بعد الجانب الانساني ال
الى الحل
السياسي الحل الحل السياسي المفترض او
المؤمل عن طريق المبعوث الاممي هو حل
تفاوضي سلمي غير ملزم وبالتالي لابد ان
تكون الاطراف عندها رغبه مشتركه في
الانتقال الى ايجاد حل سياسي وانهاء الحرب
وهذا غير متوفر الجانب الحوثي متصلب ويبحث
عن بناء دولته الخاصه ومشروعه الخاص
وبالتالي هو الذي يضغط على على على الجانب
الاممي وايضا جرفت يحاول ان يرضي الجانب
الحوثي حتى لا يفشل تفشل مساعيه بينما
تستجيب الحكومه والجانب السعودي لاي
مقترحات للمبعوث الاممي يعني الانتقال الى
جانب السلم لا يعني ان ان ان وقف الحرب
يعني صارت بفعل فاعل هي موقفه الجبهات من
ثلاث سنوات يعني السعوديه تتحدث عن سلام
بينما تقصف عشوائيا تقصف الجيش الشرعي
الوطني وتقصف ايضا الحوثيين بكل عبث
والجبهات موقف وليس هناك اي برنامج او
استراتيجيه واضحه لاستعاده الدوله حسب
الاهداف اهداف التدخل يعني التصريح
السعودي هو تصريح لملا
الفراغ
ل للكذب او للتمويه للتمويه السياسي لا
اقل ولا اكثر هي عجزت في الميدان ان تفعل
شيئا على المستوى العسكري عاجزه ان تفعل
شيئا امام الح في كل الاحوال تعاطي ايجابي
مع مقترح وقف اطلاق النار الذي تقدم به
مارتن جريفي هذا لم يصدر حتى الان من
الحوثيين واسال ضيفي من صنعاء نصر الدين
عامر لماذا لم يصدر رد مماثل من الحوثيين
بشان المقترح يعني الحوثيين قالوا ان ندرس
المقترح لم يقولوا عنه اي شيء ايجابي هل
هل هذا المقترح غير مطروح بالنسبه
للحوثيين وقف كامل لاطلاق النار في اليمن
ليس هذا هدفا حوثيا
هذا هدف هذا هدف لكل اليمنيين وقف الحرب
هو هدف ونحن كل ما نسعى اليه هو وقف الحرب
لكن مساله ان نكون ان نطلق التصريحات
والعبارات والحديث للاعلام بينما ليس هناك
خطوات في الواقع وفي الميدان هذا يعني
عباره عن عبث ليس هناك اي جديه عندما
نتحدث عن عدم قدره تنفيذ تبادل اسرى والتي
كان بالامكان ان يقوم بها الصليب الاحمر
بكل سهوله والذي احيانا تنفذها ببساطه
محليه اذا لا نستطيع ان نقفز الى الملف
السياسي والحديث عن ملفات طالما والحصار
مستمر والمشتقات النفطيه غير مسموح لها
بالدخول مطار صنعاء يعني توقف بسبب شحه
الوجود اذا الحديث عن هذه الملفات عبثيه
ولا يمكن الوصول اليها طالما ليس هناك اي
جديه من قبل الاطراف ثم ان الخلافات التي
تعصف بالطرف الاخر والفصائل المسلحه
والعصابات المسلحه التابعه له توقف اي
حلول حتى تلقي بضلالها على الملف
المفاوضات بخصوص الاسرى والان انت تسمع
مثلا من ضيفك كيف يتحدث بانهم ليسوا
متفقين على هذه الملفات ويعتبروا بان
السعودي تجاوزهم وبالفعل هناك يعني تفاوت
وتناقض واضح ما بين هذه الفصائل ولا
تستطيع ان تصل الى حل ونحن ليس من
مسؤوليتنا ان نذهب لصنع توافقات فيما
بينهم عليهم ان يتفقوا وان يكونوا قادرين
على ان يتفاوضوا معكم في المقترح مقترح
المبعوث الاممي الخاص بوقف اطلاق النار
كما قال نائب وزير الدفاع السعودي رايه
فيه وقال نتجاوب
معه كما قلت لك نحن لا نستطيع ان نطلق
لانها ستظل في اطار الخطاب الاعلامي فقط
لكن الجديه ليس هناك اي جديه هذه الملفات
تثبت الجديه فتح ميناء الحديده يثبت
الجديه لكي نستطيع ان نتجاوب مع مثل هذه
النداءات التي الى الان لا ترى النور
وانما تظل لتلميع للتلميع امام الراي
العام الدولي وان هناك حديث عن السلام كل
هذا الحديث مستهلك وليس له جديه سبق وان
اعلت السعوديه بانها اوقفت الحرب بينما
الواقع يشد ان هناك الحرب مستمره سيد نبيل
خوري هل هل على الاقل طرف التحالف السعودي
الاماراتي ومعه الحكومه الشرعيه اليمنيه
جاهزون بالفعل لوقف شامل لاطلاق النار وحل
سياسي انا لا اعتقد شخصيا لانه لو كانوا
جاهزون كانوا يوقفوا القصف الجوي يعني هذا
قرار بسيط يمكن ان ياخذه محمد بن سلمان
باشاره من يده ولم ياخذ بعد في يعني انا
اعتقد انه الاطراف الكبيره الاقليميه
والدوليه لم تقرر السلام بعد يعني هم
يقولون انه الحرب على اليمن فرضت بالفصل
السابع من الامم المتحده يعني بالقوه طيب
عال اذا كان ذلك فلماذا لا يفرضون السلام
حسب الفصل السابع يعني بالقوه ويعني
بالعقوبات على من لا يرتدع فعندك اليوم
جنود اجنبيه داخل اليمن وتطلق النار على
ثلاث جبهات او اربع جبهات وهنالك قصف جوي
مستمر يوميا فكل هذا فليت والاسلحه ما
زالت متدفقه من امريكا وبريطانيا وفرنسا
الى الامارات والى
السعوديه فهذا كله لا يعطيني تفاؤل بانه
الكبار بالفعل يريدون انهاء هذه الحرب
ومارتن جريفث يتخبط
من هنا الى هنالك وليس بيده عصى
ليستعملها لكن هذه التصريحات الايجابيه
التي اشرت الي قبل قليل اشرت الى تصريح
نائب وزير الدفاع السعودي اليست مؤشرا على
ان هنالك رغبه في انهاء او الخروج من هذه
الحرب لدى على الاقل طرف
التحالف وما اسهل
الكلام نسبه لمن يتلقى الضربات الكلام لا
يكفي فاذا كان جدي فليو قف حتى من جانب
واحد ويرى منذ اكثر من عام يعني في صيف 19
الحوثيون اعلنوا وقف شامل لاطلاق النار
وبالفعل توقفت الصواريخ وتوقفت
الجبهات
ولكن التحالف العربي لم يستجيب طيب والان
يدعون انهم هم يريدون السلام والحوثي لا
يستور دكتور فيصل الحذيفي هل هذا هو
بالفعل الموقف هل الموقف واحد من البقاء
في اليمن بالنسبه لطرفي التحالف السعوديه
والامارات تقريبا الموقف تتحكم به
السعوديه باعتباره هي الجاره المباشره لل
بالجغرافيا مع اليمن والامارات هي يعني
جاءت
بتدبير سعودي يعني لا يمكن التعويل على
انها صاحبه قرار فيما يخص عملها على الارض
لكن تبقى الحرب دعني يعني اقول في خلاصه
الكلام بعد ست سنوات حرب اليوم من يتحكم
بقرار الحرب والسلام هو الحوثيين هم
الحوثيون باعتبار انهم يعني يعززون سلطتهم
وتحويلها الى سلطه شرعيه مقنعه للجماهير
التي يحكمونها وبالتالي هم من يستجيب
للحرب او من يحرك الجبهات او من يستجيب
للسلام والسعوديه اصبحت في ورطه لا هي
قادره على انهاء استعاده الدوله عاده
الشرعيه ولا هي قادره على ان ان تفرض
سلاما الا وفق شروط الحوثيين الذين يريدون
قلنا بناء دولتهم الخاصه بشروطهم شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور فيصل الحذيفي استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه الحديده واشكر ضيفي من
صنعاء نصر الدين عامر وكيل وزاره الاعلام
التابعه للحوثيين ومن واشنطن عبر الانترنت
الدكتور نبيل خوري نائب رئيس البعثه
السياسيه الامريكيه في اليمن سابقا نهايه
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله في قراءه جديده لما وراء خبر
جديد حتى ذلكم الحين اترككم في رعايه الله
السلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم